it's fair to say
that few things have done more to
destroy
esports than match fixing whether it's
savior solo or those mdl
scrubs taking refuge in riot's cheap
cartoony-ass counter-strike knockoff
competitive gaming is riddled with
cheats
throwers whose quest for personal gain
has put
even the healthiest of scenes in peril
unfortunately once you've compromised
the competitive integrity of your esport
that's pretty much it you're branded
with a
shame that people will never let you
live down
like real cs you put one person two
steps maybe two i should probably watch
some more of your demos and stuff learn
how to get some uh
real night skins and stuff yeah
i'm gonna learn how to win yeah man we
gonna release you from the team man your
contract is over
we didn't do i buy power
see it bad later that's good
i can just play another one and whether
these disgraced stars go the route of
apology subdued apathy or volatile
aggression
all of them have at some point given up
on seeking redemption
well all of them except for this idiot
stop hang up the phone timmy what the
man on the phone wants you to do is
something called match fixing
don't do what he says i present unto
thee joshua
steele nissan one of the smartest
saltiest and most stubbornly loyal
savants
cs go has ever seen unfortunately
after participating in the infamous
north american
match fixing scandal of 2015 he also
became its most maligned
title under my belt steel what do you
have
skins from embedding bruh and yet in
spite of being handed an
indefinite ban from participating in any
valve sponsored events
he never gave up on himself even when it
looked like
everyone else had i never felt like i
fully
scratched that itch so i'm just like you
know what i'm gonna do it because
i think i'm still capable i still have
that itch
and it's the game that i've
i started in and it's the game that got
me into this in the first place so
so why is it that steel never stopped
grinding
how has he managed to redeem himself and
in what sense did his counter-strike
career
finally get the ending it deserved and
is there even more to come
yes i have it yeah i don't have a i
didn't 80 them
okay i don't know why can't i hit this
guy he just slid
man he's on his he's like
and then he's like moon walking away
like michael jackson man
[Music]
okay so if you've never heard of steel
you've a
never taken the time to learn your
smokes b
aren't familiar with literally the
biggest scandal in cs go history
and c you don't get as much pleasure as
i do from binging some good old rank
s rage compilations that [ __ ] gives me
life do it again
i'm about to die guys i shot a you shot
this game
you see steel is a true counter-strike
og
after making a name for himself in
source he brought his wares to global
offensive
where he developed a reputation for two
things
in an esport where mechanics were
usually prioritized over mind games
steel stood out for his savviness and
game sense the dude had a massive iq
and it stood out in a region typically
known for being pbrained
he was a mastermind whom people looked
to for advice
even if he could be a little harsh
when delivering it
don't tell me you're going to go in
without smoking out ct or heaven
and you're just all going to push in
through maine here no one's going to go
into checker and clear it
smoke thank [ __ ] god
now no your teammate should not be
jumping up there you just smoked a
forklift you can cross into the bomb
site safely
you should be crossing into the bomb
site safely your teammates about to get
banged out by this guy in ct spawn
am i right
oh my jstone
you're lucky this guy blows you need
to go to the gym this front bum is
nothing to be proud of
nothing to be proud of now if those
clips don't make it obvious already
steel is known for having an abrasive
personality
he's an authoritarian who always thinks
he knows better
since for the most part he probably does
guys i'm saying what to do please just
do it
so when things don't go as planned he
can get a bit
well temperamental
[Music]
but for better or for worse that's who
steele was
a jackass but a genius even those who
didn't particularly care for his
whiny explosive outbursts couldn't help
but respect the fact that he had a mind
for the game
and as the in-game leader of the
recently successful i buy power lineup
was helping to put north american
counter-strike on the map and either
power gonna have to hold on
it's gonna be very difficult as the
smokes surely not to deter them the
flashes go in
and the push comes ldlc losing two
people
to atk in swag azk with another one oh
he gets another
azk with three happy though gonna be
able to take down one it's a one on two
happy i think this is it he's gotta save
it for his team and ah there it is
i my power take it they're gonna go
through they eliminate ldlc
in an insane semi-final as much as i
love hating i buy power
you can't be too angry they're showing
america they're putting america back on
the map
they're they're showing that we can play
with the best and then
as you probably know in august of 2014
he uh threw it all away
he's gonna have two right there can they
line up for him what is he doing
why did he hesitate so much doesn't
matter has the cc gets one
gets taken down hayes was so very low
they lined up perfectly for him but for
some reason oh he says he wanted a knife
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that's right despite supposedly
being
galaxy brained steele made the
profoundly
stupid decision alongside a few of his
teammates to throw
an official match for skins and of
course
when valve found out they were [ __ ]
steele and his co-conspirators were
banned from competing in
any valve affiliated events including
the majors for how long you ask
well that's the thing valve didn't
specify
at first it seemed as if the ban might
be lifted in a year or so and that the
shame that they'd have to live down
would be short-lived
when it first happened it was like oh
this is indefinite
so we never knew what indefinite meant
meant like
you know maybe there's an appeal process
maybe in a year they'll change the
ruling whatever
but as time went on and with valve
remaining
radio silent it became increasingly
clear that their ban
was likely to last forever as was the
shame
you need to burn i don't give a [ __ ]
about him and i don't give a [ __ ] about
steel either
that guy he can be the friendliest guy
he could be the biggest troll piece of
[ __ ] he wants on stream
but that guy also can burn because they
knew so
no mercy needless to say this took a
huge toll on steel
the public already thought of him as
something of a toxic
asshat and given the damage he'd done to
north american cs
a good portion of the community was
happy to watch him and the rest of i buy
power
burn beyond just shooting somebody on
the stage i think taking a dive for
money
is the worst thing that you can do
inside of competition
i believe there should be a permanent
non-reversible ban
from any kind of competition for people
who do that
for match fixing what started as a
reprimand became an
all-consuming curse a mark that couldn't
be erased
like this is a stain on my life this
affects me like everywhere i go
so understandably he began to look
elsewhere
overwatch pubg anything that could prove
a suitable substitute for cs go
but for a die-hard-like steel it just
wasn't the same
when i tried playing overwatch for
example i kind of did it
not because i really enjoyed the game i
did it because
i didn't really have any other options
that i wanted to compete and it was like
close enough it was like the only fps
that was
close enough to counter-strike but it
was still so super far it's like more of
a moba than it is
uh you know what whatever counter-strike
is in spite of his perceived betrayal
steel was a dude who'd given his heart
and soul to counter-strike
he really truly loved the game
and was willing to do whatever it took
to not only compete in it
but redeem himself in the eyes of those
he disappointed
and to his credit against every odd
every expectation he did just that
from streams to demo reviews to a sea of
educational youtube content
steel set out to rebuild his reputation
to leave the counter-strike community
better off than he'd found it in the
hope that valve would take notice
and well pity he even took the time to
educate viewers about mental health
how to create the perfect tinder profile
and even poked fun at his
own plight in a psa warning against the
perils of match fixing
don't do what he says but in the end
it didn't matter what steel did valve
refused to budge
even as third-party tournament
organizers began lifting the eye by
power players bands
claiming they'd served their time
valve's major ban
remained intact in spite of his
incredible mind for the game
steele spent years spearheading lesser
rosters to subpar results one
by one they've fallen a-zk remains and
dead to rights he is ago eliminating
torque the first to fall in tours
and despite his age the notoriety
surrounding him
and the finality of his ban steele
refused to call it quits he didn't coach
or
fall into the comfy embrace of full-time
streaming
he wanted to win so he went out and
found an
org that felt he was still worth
believing
i play in chaos and sometimes i wish i
didn't
it's mainly just a joke because our
results are so bad
with chaos it felt as if steele hadn't
just found a group of
young hungry fraggers whom he could
mentor but
this kind of weird dysfunctional family
a goofy grassroots underdog who
understood that
nowadays you don't need a major sticker
to be successful at cs go
they also understood that in order to
get that sticker they'd need to work for
it
but not without having some fun along
the way that is one ugly human oh there
we go oh god the nose is getting bigger
somehow
who's that guy
but right as chaos were on the brink of
becoming a
genuinely good team a new opportunity
presented itself to steel
[Applause]
yeah that's all donna
valerant presented a second chance for
steel
his exiled former eye by power teammates
and just about anyone else who had grown
disillusioned with cs go
and while jumping ship to an unknown and
unproven challenger definitely posed
considerable risk
it also offered steel the competition
and fresh start that he
desperately wanted but as appealing as
valorent was to steal
he had unfinished business with
counter-strike he'd set out to do
something special with chaos
and as he told espn esports he intended
to see it through
for me to switch at that point in time
when the game first came out
would be very risky for me because i
wouldn't know what to expect
and i feel like i hadn't really done
what i set out to do
with chaos and beautifully enough
he did five on two standing between them
and getting a very clean 2-0 bent it
goes down as well and that's going to be
it chaos wins 16 to six
and now they know where you are leave
creeping up looking for a triple he gets
it
16-3 what's a final map from chaos he
has an azer then make it just lia's
steals got a necessary fright chaos
have done it they've done it in three
and they've done it in style
in what is presumably the last
competitive cs go match he will ever
play
steele achieved arguably his best
tournament result to date
helping chaos secure a top four finish
at esl one cologne north america
and with that achievement chaos eeked
their way into the top
20 rankings of counter-strike meaning
that their
sweet steely prince could finally put
his cs go career
to rest now that i'm you know getting
the team to a level
where it's like we're top 20 in the
world in cs
and i can be happy with that and i can
kind of pass them off like
okay you guys are in like a pretty good
situation that you're nestled in at the
moment
top 20 you're an epl you're going to get
invites to other tournaments
there's another player available that
you can get now
let's make this transition as seamless
as possible in the weeks following
chaos's cologne finish
it was announced that steele would be
leaving cs go
to join a hundred thieves valorent
roster
needless to say the community was
extremely sad to see
steele go he'd long since lived down his
disgrace
and the consensus was that he'd finally
joined the tier one org of which he'd
always been worthy
something he reflected upon with the
immortal minds podcast
when i was like actually considering you
know what
what possibilities are there for
valerian and also the
the fact that eventually down the line
i'll probably be you know replaced by my
team in counter-strike
and then you know what happens when i
get replaced i'm going to rebuild again
for the how many time i'm like i don't
really want to do that
i'd rather just go and start fresh in
valorem
where i don't have to have these
artificial ceilings it isn't clear what
kind of results are in store for steel
or if valorent will finally afford him
the opportunity to scratch that
competitive itch
once and for all what is clear is that
in addition to
derailing his life steel's fateful
decision to match fix
strangely gave him everything he ever
asked for
in the end steele did redeem himself as
both a competitor and
content creator he just ended up taking
a much more difficult path to getting
there than he would have liked
you know i started realizing like okay
like there's some
things in my life that need to change
there's some like ways i look at
life and look at this and how you know
i'm living in everything that needs to
change
and slowly over time i started like
doing things to kind of
be better i don't know whether or not
i'd be where i am today in terms of like
personal maturity or outlook or how i
see life
you know had i not been punished for for
my actions
so i don't know like maybe there is like
a moral of the story at the end of it
in spite of all the hate and hardship
steel did finally get the happy ending
he deserved
not by closing his eyes and willing it
into existence
but by taking action by owning up to his
mistakes
making reparations and remaining the
steeliest son of a [ __ ] cs go
has ever seen one down
last player standing one enemy remaining
how [ __ ] happy are you that we get to
go back to some good old steel rage
clips are you as happy as i am it's just
it's just like it's like all reliable
okay
[Laughter]
it's so good he has a he has a whininess
that i just love you know what i mean
like there's a certain like
what are you doing why because
it's scary oh it's the best dude it's so
good yeah it's so good